so yesterday was the second stop in my
what is a woman College Tour this was a
week that began 46 years ago it feels
like with three major medical
associations writing to the doj and
calling for my arrest and the arrest of
the other uh high profile quote unquote
conservatives who criticized them a day
later Media Matters launches their smear
campaign exposing the long suppressed
fact that I was once 23 years old and
finally yesterday I screened the film
and spoke at University of Illinois
Urbana-Champaign and protesters
swarmed outside the auditorium doing
their best unsuccessfully to disrupt and
kind of drown me out
frankly the events of this week are
they're making me start to suspect
that there are some people in this
country who really don't like me and I
still can't imagine why that would be
the case I'm such a lovable guy
but the protesters last night were
vastly outnumbered by
supporters by people who support when I
say supporters I mean supporter people
who support uh
you know objective truth and rationality
um we fill the room to its capacity of
350 350 people and we had to turn 400
more people away wasn't all that long
ago that I was giving College speeches
to crowds of like 40 or 50 so this has
been an interesting
change of pace and as mentioned
protesters were kept outside the
auditorium were allowed to remain in the
hallway for some reason I'm told they
made a few attempts to get inside the
room and when that was not successful
they settled for chanting and sometimes
even singing right outside the door
unfortunately for the rest of us they
chose a song to sing that requires them
to hit notes
very much outside their vocal range
listen
[Music]
positions
[Music]
[Music]
because
[Music]
I was interested to see that video after
the event because I heard some of that
noise while I was giving the speech and
I I didn't know that they were
attempting to sing actually it sounded
to me like somebody was drowning a bag
of cats in the hallway and I wasn't
concerned about that
um and I'm relieved to find out that no
animals were hurt even if we could not
say the same for our eardrums when it
was time to leave protesters came around
to the exit to you know flip me off and
cuss me out and uh presenting a
compelling argument ultimately
unpersuasive though I think as we were
getting ready to drive away they came
over to the car uh to chant some more
here's what that looked like
yes
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you know maybe they're right trans
rights are human rights I didn't believe
it the first 600 times it was chanted
but the 601st time really sank in almost
anyway I think I need to hear it maybe
another 600 times before I decide but
there's there's one short clip from last
night a couple of short clips actually
that I think are worth more serious
reflection
so going back inside while my speech was
still ongoing
somebody with the school I think this is
somebody with the school made an attempt
to quiet the protesters down now it
would have been easiest to just kick
them out of the building as they don't
actually have any right to gather inside
the building with the express intent of
disrupting an event but they were
allowed to anyway remain there um even
though it's actually against the campus
rules to you know be disruptive like
that inside the building campus decided
not to fully enforce their rules feeble
attempts were made to reason with them
but I want you to listen to this
exchange here it is
it is still disruptive to the speaker
inside an audience inside we would
protect an event similarly okay well him
being here is
dangerous you can encourages
so she says him being here is disruptive
to my being as a whole
and someone else off camera who's crying
says that uh I encourage violence and so
I'm dangerous
and they continued with this line listen
well his documentary is descriptive to
the trans community and there being as a
whole and him being here makes a large
group of the people on this campus that
makes this campus what it is feel unsafe
if you don't feel protected we don't
feel appreciated and it's disgusting and
disheartening
so that's why we're here and that's why
we're going to stand here I understand
[Music]
right so there it is again my presence
is disruptive to her being
and the being of every trans person and
it makes a large portion of the student
body feel unsafe now
um I know that we're accustomed to
hearing this kind of thing from the left
but the mistake we make is to assume
that they're just sort of putting on an
act
that this is all uh you know playing it
up for the for the cameras
I don't believe that they are I I think
this is truly what they think it's what
they believe
we know that college students especially
believe it because they've been
conditioned into this belief system from
birth and so when they say it's
disruptive to my being it puts me a
danger and danger it's a threat they
really believe that that's what they
actually think that's why they're there
now as far as they're concerned
their very being is threatened by my
ideas and my presence and not just my
presence and my ideas but the ideas
shared by many of the people in the room
but but listen to the phrasing there
because she's not just saying that her
life is threatened
but instead she's saying that her being
is threatened
and she's right in a certain sense now I
am not threatening her physical
existence in the slightest nobody in the
room was threatening her physical
existence in a slightness
but what she really means is that her
conception of her own existence her
perception of herself and of reality her
self-identity are destabilized are
thrown into disarray when they come
within physical proximity of somebody
who will not affirm them
and this is a terrifying thing for her
and and for me too
but for a different reason
okay here's why I find it terrifying
I find it terrifying
that we are populating Society with
people who are this fragile this
helpless and dependent people who cannot
function who are reduced to tears and
paralysis if their internal conception
of reality is contradicted in the
slightest Way by anyone anywhere
what is terrifying is not the prospect
that these people will get out into the
real world and encounter harsh reality
and just fall apart
no that would be a good thing I I wish
that that would happen
for for the sake of society and for
their own sake that they need to fall
apart they need to be intellectually and
emotionally unmade so that a mature and
rational person can rise from the rubble
this is in many ways the process of
growing up
but no the terror the terrifying truth
is that such a collapse will not happen
most likely
they will never encounter the real world
because the real world
in our culture at least has reordered
itself to protect and Foster the
delusions of the most fragile Among Us
this is unsustainable of course
and what it means is that in order to
stop them from collapsing personally
Society will have to collapse instead
it'll collapse because it simply cannot
carry the weight of all of these false
ideas and false assumptions the burden
is too heavy
to cumbersome
this is the outcome of raising
generations of people who believe that
it is the responsibility of every
stranger they come across on the street
to affirm their own self-understanding
you know they say this is what I want to
believe about myself and about the world
and you must tell me that it is true or
else you are a threat to my existence
and to my being
that's what you really meant
and that's why they were gathered with
their signs in the hallway
that's even why they were singing
Bohemian Rhapsody oddly enough
and that's why we must oppose them
no matter what and that'll do it for us
today as we move over to the members
blog hope to see you there if not talk
to you on Monday Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]